Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est la cinquième vidéo sur le Rubik's Cube et on touche le bout en fait.
On est à l'avant dernière étape pour que vous puissiez résoudre un Rubik's Cube en moins de 2 minutes avec seulement 5 formules.
Et on va apprendre la cinquième formule aujourd'hui.
Le premier jour on a vu comment faire la première face, avec la première couronne en une seule fois.
Le deuxième jour on a vu comment faire la deuxième couronne.
Le troisième jour comment faire la croix.
Le quatrième jour, donc hier, comment faire correspondre les cubes du centre avec la deuxième couronne.
Aujourd'hui c'est une opération un petit peu délicate. Un petit peu complexe, on va se l'avouer, on ne va pas se mentir !
Il faut qu'on place les coins aux endroits correspondants.
Il faut qu'on place les coins de telle sorte à ce que les 3 faces de ces coins correspondent aux 3 faces à laquelle ils sont associés.
Si on regarde sur ce coin là, on a jaune, orange vert, alors que ça devrait être jaune, rouge, bleu.
Ici c'est bleu, jaune, rouge. Ça devrait être jaune, vert, rouge.
Et pour celui-ci, ça match. On a le bleu qui va être ici.
Le orange qui va être là
et le jaune qui va être là.
Oui, il n'est pas positionné dans le bon sens, mais ça se sera le sujet de la vidéo de demain.
Pour l'instant, on veut juste que le coin soit au bon endroit, c'est tout.
Et comme dans la vidéo d'hier, la formule qu'on va apprendre aujourd'hui va nous permettre de faire un saute-mouton, un petit peu, entre les coins.
Un des coins va rester fixe et tous vont bouger d'un cran vers la droite en sautant celui qui est fixe pour le premier.
C'est pas très clair...
C'est-à-dire que si je me positionne comme ça, celui-ci restera fixe.
Celui-ci passera là
lui passera ici
et lui passera ici.
Comme hier, si vous ne choisissez pas le bon coin en fixe, c'est pas grave, il suffira de réappliquer la formule, 1, 2, ou 3 fois grand maximum.
Pour moi je vous l'avoue, c'est la formule la plus compliquée à retenir, parce que j'arrive pas à lui trouver une logique particulière
j'ai pas de moyen mnémotechnique de m'en rappeler.
Donc je l'ai d'abord appris réellement par cœur.
Et après je me l'a suis mis dans les doigts.
Un petit peu comme ceux qui jouent d'un instrument de musique, c'est peut-être votre cas
des fois on ne connaît plus la partition de tête, on n'est plus capable de l'expliquer, par contre on sait prendre la guitare et le faire ou prendre le piano et le faire.
Le corps a enregistré l'information, a enregistré les mouvements.
Plus on pratique, et plus ça devient facile.
La formule c'est:
Gauche/Droite inversé, Haut/Gauche inversé, Haut inversé/Droite, Haut/Gauche, Haut inversé/Gauche inversé.
Et je l'écris comme chaque jour aussi dans le descriptif de la vidéo.
Je passe de l'autre coté de la caméra pour vous faire voir.
Après avoir observé mon cube, je vois que si je mets bien ce coin là
là où il va, c'est-à-dire avec du orange, du bleu, du jaune
comme les trois du coin.
Celui-ci: vert, jaune, orange ira ici.
Vert, jaune orange, on est bon.
Celui-ci ira là.
Le vert, rouge, jaune
vert, rouge, jaune, ça correspond bien aux faces.
Et celui-ci ira ici.
On est bon !
L'endroit qui va rester fixe, ce sera celui-ci.
Donc je le place en haut à gauche par rapport à moi.
Au plus éloigné de moi et au plus sur la gauche, juste là.
J'applique la formule et j'essaye d'y trouver un peu de logique
Gauche et droite inversé, ça veut dire que la gauche je l'avance vers moi
et la droite également.
Haut/Gauche inversé
donc haut dans le bon sens
gauche inversé
et ensuite, haut inversé et droite
Il ne me reste plus qu'à faire
Haut Gauche, Haut inversé, Gauche inversé.
Haut
Gauche
Haut inversé
Gauche inversé.
Et c'est terminé !
Et si on vérifie, les coins sont bien positionnés par rapport aux faces.
Alors pas forcément bien dans le bon sens comme celui, ça c'est un hasard.
Mais ils sont tous bien à leur bonne place.
Peut-être que vous n'y voyez pas une grande difficulté, moi en tout cas c'est l'endroit qui m'avait posé un petit peu problème.
Du coup, on s'arrête là pour aujourd'hui. Je pense que juste cette formule mérite une vidéo et une journée complète pour assimiler.
Maintenant que les coins sont à leur place, il va juste à nous rester juste à les mettre dans le bon sens, à bien les positionner.
Et ça, ça va être grâce à une formule que vous connaissez déjà.
On verra comment faire avec demain.
Et ce Rubik's Cube sera enfin résolu !
Entrainez-vous bien et rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !